welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Katherine Panter brick a professor of
anthropology health and global affairs
at Yale University professor Pantera
bricks research consists of critical
analyses of health and well-being across
key stages of human development giving
special attention to the impact of
poverty disease malnutrition armed
conflict and social marginalization her
focus on children in global adversity
has included bio cultural research with
street children refugees and war
affected adolescents she has published
widely on child and adolescent health
including articles on conflict and
mental health in Afghanistan infant
survival and famines stricken Niger
growth retardation in nepali slums
biomarkers of stress in the context of
violence and homelessness and the
effectiveness of Public Health and
humanitarian interventions today we'll
talk with Professor pan Tobruk about the
research she's done in Afghanistan
focusing on the mental health of
children
welcome professor Panther BRIC Thank You
Marilyn
let's begin with an overview of your
research tell us about it we conducted
the first large-scale mental health
survey in Afghanistan and before that
there was simply no data to speak of
that was systematic so to put the
research into context there's about a
billion children who live in
conflict-affected countries and in 2009
there were 36 armed conflict six of
which is scarlet scarlet escalated to
the intensity of war including
Afghanistan so conflict and health is a
very big problem in terms of researchers
very little research that focuses on
adolescents which are the next
generation rather than adults and very
little research that looks at family
contexts and community context rather
than clinics and also that takes a
longitudinal look at how things evolve
over time so we did a study of a
thousand six hundred children and
and 600 parents and teachers we looked
at this in the community setting and we
did as longitudinal work so that was
quite a landmark study and what was the
impetus for the study why did you do it
it was the product of working for about
10 years on children in global adversity
so homeless children war affected
children refugee children and confirm
there was a disconnect between the
health interventions we put in place and
the everyday lives of children so we
wanted to really illustrate what matters
in the lives of children their needs now
and their aspirations for the future so
to do that as an anthropologist we
really try to look at what children
themselves have to say in what civilian
populations have to say because they're
the least studied I say let's talk about
your methodology how did you do the
research we worked in schools it was
quite evident that that was the really
only setting that was possible to work
in because we wanted to interview
face-to-face children in privacy and we
also had to ensure the safety of the
field team so working in marks consumes
would not be possible to do the field
team was three local women and three men
who were interviewing from going from
school to school in a very politically
and economically insecure environment so
our office was sprayed by gunfire during
the 2006 riots an NGO pulled out support
in a rural area because the car female
interviewers came after dark so those
were kind of challenges if you want to
work with establishing the random sample
of school and contacting boys and girls
and fathers and mothers was really the
most difficult thing to do we were
unable to access children out of school
but there's about 68 percent of children
nationally who have enrolled in school
at the moment so you were talking about
a very large proportion of children and
an ever-growing proportion of children I
was going to ask you that because I I
would have been under the impression
that many children do not attend school
so 68% is much higher than I would have
thought it's very fast growing education
that the premium families
that those who can often put their
children and struggle to keep them there
we're talking about 11 to 16 year olds
so in the context of boys having to
really work for the castle economy and
girls at the age of marriage it's quite
remarkable that those children still get
to school stop because of curtailed
education and Taliban some 16 eurozone
primary classes of course so it's all a
mixed mix of Ages and is it equal boys
and girls or are there more boys than
girls there's obviously more boys and
girls about three-quarters of boys and
the lesser proportion of of girls but
they have girl in boys schools very
often then the the other point to make
was really that when you're walking in
working in conflict settings you're very
often guided by a paradigm that mental
health is consequent of trauma of war
and I wanted to broaden that agenda a
little bit to think about risking them
in a more interdisciplinary way so I was
trying to marry the best of Psychiatry
of the best of Social Sciences and in
psychiatry you want to understand what
mental this health disorders are and who
has them so you can treat individuals in
the social sciences you might want to
think about how this suffering comes
about and why it's occurring and how
it's experienced and coped with so how
its articulated in a society setting and
was it difficult to do the work in the
schools how were you received as I say
we worked through local partners so we
had a Ministry of Education letter which
helps open doors we had we worked
through Social Work professor in
Peshawar and psychiatrist in Kabul I'm
an anthropologist my research partner
mark Eckerman is a Middle Eastern
specialist so we've put together the
kind of team that would be able to be
very effective we implemented it with a
Kabul based research agency called Altai
and it was funded by medical charity
it was difficult the most difficult
thing was to get this random sampling of
schools because you had to have a list
of schools which didn't exist at the
national level only district level and a
list of children which only existed at
class level relevant school level so
that was a challenge but in itself
participation is not that difficult
there Afghans have a great tradition of
hospitality so when you get to talk to
them they invite you in and we had
because we took our time and we built
rapport it was quite extraordinary
really children told us it was the first
time that somebody had come to ask them
what their difficulties were mothers
told them told us it was the first time
they had been allowed outside the home
to visit the school and to to meet this
child's teacher and the teachers told us
it was the first time they've been asked
to reflect on how difficulties might
interfere with education performance so
that was participations day was very
high I hadn't saw the value of that
uh-huh and you mentioned that your
research is interdisciplinary can you
talk about that a little bit more so
with as I said we tried to approach it
from a bottom-up the social sciences
approach so we included a survey that
looked at mental health is all ism what
they were with interview approaches that
would understand us the how and the why
of suffering as it existed one of the
things we found was that the most
powerful predictor of poor mental health
was violence but and that you can find
out through your survey but the
explanation for that violence is only
realized through the interview and what
was interesting was that the violence
was not just contingent on war it was
not just a spectacular form of military
violence that mattered to the life of
children it was very much the violence
experienced through accidents and no
resulting health care or beatings in the
home or stabbings and brutality in the
neighborhood so the message is really
not to just get drawn into the visible
forms of violence that we expect
bombardments explosion the American war
landmine injury but also the more
invisible forms of violence that exist
and affect children very deeply what we
call everyday violence
okay so that was one of your findings
were there any others their findings in
terms of prevalence was that one out of
five children suffered from mental
health is always in a clinical range
that's twice what you expecting that age
group so it tells you that mental health
is a big issue in Afghanistan the more
interesting finding might be that you
could turn it around and say four out of
five children live in that toxic milieu
of poverty and violence and yet show a
few of the symptoms in the clinical
range so there's that those are you
could call them the resilient children
risk and resilience is like to face of
the coin you have the vulnerability and
the survivors we tend to think of
children as victims of orbit also
surviving it so that proportion is
showing you that yes you can focus on
the one out of five but it's very deeply
interesting to understand how the four
out of five managed to survive war in
those circumstances that is and come out
with better outcomes that you might
expect let's talk about the mental
health issues themselves what are some
of the mental health problems that you
saw when most often in you finding that
age group boys would have conduct
disorders at schools and girls would
have emotional disorders of depression
and in Afghanistan it's very much all of
them depression internalizing disorders
so a great deal of sorrow great deal of
grief and and what we simply call
depression what I call the loss of hope
in the future so there's there's grief
related to war and the loss of your
beloved and your relatives if you lose
your father for instance you're an
incredible precarious position because
your father is the person who might get
you your preferred cross cousin in a
marriage for instance or you become you
fall at the mercy of an uncle so losing
your father or losing your mother is
really a huge loss of social support and
so when that happens you are in a
vulnerable position in society
you don't have somebody to fight your
corner if you speak so there's that I
would say that's the most important the
depressive symptoms the most important
mental health problems that we found did
a majority of the children you spoke to
did the more dirty of them have lost in
their lives yeah everybody and I think
the scale of losses is enormous I mean
you have people having 30 relatives
killed in the war and the wars been
going on for three decades so it
cascades from one generation to be
generated to the next so that's pretty
much everybody that is affected and are
you doing the follow-up survey we did a
follow-up survey which was pretty
interesting in the sense that in the
absence of a in the absence of an
intervention mental health outcomes were
better a year later and that was a real
surprise I was expecting them to go
downhill and I I understand those
findings by the fact that I could only
follow up those who had stayed in school
and due to the absence of record-keeping
we couldn't follow those who had left
school so we lost about 40% of the
sample in Kabul and it is those families
that were able to anchor their children
at school that's a measure of strength
and resilience despite that there's my
illness despite the threat of being
evicted some families live in tents in
the middle of the communal courtyard
with no heating and no electricity
that's the precariousness of the housing
that you find other families are three
families to a room despite that they
were able to keep their children at
school and so it's not surprising that
their mental health outcomes didn't
necessarily deteriorate those that did
within that sample talked of family
harmony and unity being difficult so the
diary phrases et [ __ ] wafted meaning
the family had conflict there was severe
beatings inside the house there was all
the time some kind of frustration that
erupted and that made life very
difficult so it says that family
violence is really
enduring predictor of children's mental
health even in the context of that
extraordinary military violence that's
going on in the larger picture so they
kind of have a double whammy then the
violence of the war and then the
violence at home yeah I think of several
layers so there's the most spectacular
one and the most invisible one and I
think you need to address both and I
think you need to really understand how
difficult it is to struggle in that
context I mean I you know professor at
Kabul at that time makes $50 a day
that's not enough to pay the rent in the
context of these huge rent rises because
of the expatriates presence so it really
is a struggle and that the the two kinds
of violence are linked because your
frustrations from the structural kind of
violence that's exterior kind of
includes inside the house and causes
additional and the health of the you
know the mental health of the caregiver
and the child was very closely related
that tells you that you need to
intervene at family level rather than
just individual level okay so based on
your findings what are your
recommendations for improving children's
mental health my the recommendations in
humanitarian settings is what clear it
is to provide psychosocial intervention
like psychotherapy to children who have
post-traumatic stress disorder type of
distress that's consequent on trauma and
that's the tip of the iceberg and that's
looking after psychological well-being
for the rest and my mental health
intervention would be a structural
intervention it would be to address the
social economic and political barriers
that make children's life a misery
so I remember an Afghan father telling
me that the broken economy is at the
root of all the man's misery and I
remember that phrase because to me it
would be the first thing would be to
repair the broken economy to fix the
overcrowding and provide adequate
housing for these families so that
children might have electricity at night
so they can study after school and not
have and on top of their carpet weaving
before and after school to help the
family pay the teachers are very decent
wage because some of them have two jobs
they clock in
school go and get a second job crop back
into school because you need two jobs to
keep your family going and so in that
context the economy is really something
that you have to fix first and foremost
so I think working across sectors would
be a very useful thing to do and not
narrowly think of the rest mental health
as being just war and just a mental
health intervention and based on your
recommendations do you think that they
have any possibility of being
implemented the yes there is a big basic
package of health services in
Afghanistan and it's very unusual I
think about Cambodia is another country
where mental health is selected as one
of the basic components for all health
services so that's a very big progress
in that way and that signals that mental
health is a huge issue and so there is
there is work to do to structurally make
it happen so that mental health is it is
not a psychiatric tertiary care but seen
at the primary level and working across
sectors but that will take some time but
I think the were rowing in the right
direction wonderful and what was the
greatest surprise to you in doing the
study the greatest surprise was the
expression of determinants hope that
children had which I didn't expect I was
expecting to see distress but not really
this incredible determination to get to
where they wanted to be and this
idealist expression of their future to
give you an example we ask the children
to draw themselves in the present and in
the future and they drew themselves in
the present with flags and in tears and
in the future as excellent doctors or
remarkable engineers or dedicated
teachers and I remember one girl who was
a street child and worked selling
plastics in Kabul afternoon before
school and she drew herself in drags in
the present and then in the future she
drew herself with a table and a
microphone and she said she was going to
be the first female presented to radio
Kabul and presented like you Marilyn
that's what she wanted to do
and you could say you know she'll never
get there but that's the wrong attitude
the right has did you say that she had
the hope and that gave meaning to her
life and that was very that aspiration
is very important to the future so I
think in mental health for instance
Westerners think of we tend to think
about explaining present well-being in
terms of the past and especially looking
at the impact of war on present-day
psychological health Afghans articulate
the impact of the future for their
present health so it's where they're
going to go to determine that makes
meaning to that everyday suffering and a
girl who has that kind of determination
and hope is a girl who is in bed of
psychological health and somebody has
lost all hope and hope is what keeps you
going it keeps a man standing up and
it's the anchor of resilience in the
midst of great suffering mm-hmm and it
is surprising that there is so much hope
still there it is surprising so much
hopes it's very important to follow
through you're building schools and
inviting refugees to come home in
Afghanistan so you have to have the
follow-through to provide socio-economic
opportunities otherwise you're turning a
very hopeful generation into angry
frustrated men and bitter people and so
that's very important and that's an
ethic of hope if you weren't in terms of
reconstruction with the massive funds
going in the country but I remember one
woman and she said it very simply in
four little words she said life feeds on
hope that's a very beautiful phrase it
is so my take-home message for globe
mentor global mental health might be two
things it might be first of all work at
the family level to strengthen families
and really connect very deeply with the
everyday life of children and their
parents and work across sectors mental
health social and economic sciences and
the second would be not just to
alleviate suffering but to build on that
hope in the aspiration which is so
important in the lives of kids hopefully
those things will happen in Afghanistan
thank you very much for being here with
us today and sharing some of your work
Thank You Marlene for more information
about professor Panter brick and her
work please visit our website at
edu backslash Macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale